it's often difficult for anyone to find
anyone to talk to that will actually
listen another thing that's really
strange about this listening is that if
you listen to people they will tell you
the weirdest bloody things so fast you
just cannot believe it so if you're
having a conversation with someone and
it's dull it's because you're stupid
you're not listening to them properly
because they're weird if you're actually
communicating with them and they were
telling you how weird they really are it
would be anything but boring we're
having a conversation I'm deciding I'm
going to listen to you that's different
than how people generally communicate
because usually when they communicate
they're doing something like okay we're
gonna have a conversation and I'm gonna
tell you why I'm right and I'll win if
you agree or maybe you're having a
conversation where you're trying to
impress the person you're talking to so
you're not listening to them at all
you're just thinking about what you're
going to say next the next time you get
into an argument with your wife or your
friend or a small group of friends stop
the discussion for a moment and for an
experiment Institute this rule each
person can speak up for himself only
after he has first restated the ideas
and feelings of the previous speaker
accurately what accurately means is they
have to agree with your restatement now
that's an annoying thing to do because
if someone is talking to you and you
disagree with them the first thing you
want to do is take their argument make
the stupidest possible thing out of it
that you can that's the straw man and
then demolish it but that isn't what you
do you say okay well I'm going to take
what you told me and maybe I'm even
going to make your argument stronger
than the one you made that's useful if
you're dealing with someone that you
have to live with because maybe they
can't bloody well Express themselves
very well but they have something to say
so you make their argument strong hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
how you can be a lot more articulate
with Jordan Peterson enjoy
rule number two is get everyone's
attention first here's a good rule if
you're learning to speak publicly I
never say a word
till everyone is 100 quiet
and that's it's a great way to start a
talk because
you're set in the frame eh and if the
frame is we'll all talk while you're
talking the message is well you can talk
this is a place where everybody can talk
it's like no it's not
this is a place where people paid to
hear me talk so I'm not going to talk
till everyone's listening
and so then you get that Stillness and
then you just wait because that
Stillness turns into an expectation and
then it comes turns into a kind of
nervous expectations like what the hell
is he doing it's not manipulative it's a
sense of timing it's like just when
that's right you think okay now it's
time to start well that never the
interesting thing about that nervous
expectation is from an audience
perspective We're In It Together yeah I
mean there is into that silence there's
a togetherness to it of course it's the
union of everyone's attention yeah yeah
and that's and that's a great thing I
mean you love that at a concert when
everyone it's not silenced then but when
everyone's attention is Unified and
everyone's moving in unison it's like
we're all worshiping the same thing
right is when that would be the point of
the conversation the point of the
lecture and the worship is the direction
of attention towards it and it's uni
it's communion because everyone's doing
it at the same time and so
I mean there's not much difference
between lecture theater and a church in
that regard right it's the same
fundamental layout and structure and
they're very integrally associated with
one another one really grew out of the
other the lectures either grow out of
the church so it's it's perfectly
reasonable to be thinking about it in
those terms rule number three is be
meaningfully engaged what do you see in
that sort of path that we're walking of
figuring out how to have better
conversations
there's a I write about this a fair bit
and 12 rules for life there's a chapter
I think it's chapter nine I think that's
right uh assume that the person's that
you're listening to know something you
don't it's kind of a derivation of some
of some things that I learned from Carl
Rogers who was a great clinician great
20th century clinician his star sort of
Rose during the 1960s he was a humanist
um he was a Christian Missionary when he
was a kid but he dropped that and he
became a Leading Light humanistic
psychology and he was really interested
in the preconditions for therapeutic
conversation
um and he thought that
well
if you were going to
engage in the process of therapy with a
client that the client had to bring to
the session before he or she arrived the
willingness to make things better that
would be the first thing yeah right so
that and I've done
therapy that was Court mandated like I
wouldn't recommend that that just
doesn't work very well you know because
you can't force someone to be better
they have to kind of come already
thinking that there's a bunch of things
they don't know and that their life
could be better than it already is
that's a good
position to take when you're engaging in
a conversation with someone it's like
look if you already know enough
more power to you man
you know
but if you're suffering more than you
think is necessary which is like highly
probable or or more than you think is
desirable which basically means if
you're suffering more than you think is
desirable that means that you're way
more ignorant than you need to be right
that's what it means because maybe you
have an illness you don't know how to
cure it yeah maybe you're having a fight
with someone you don't know how to get
out of it maybe you're failing at work
and you don't know what to do about it
it's like you're ignorant and no wonder
because people are ignorant and so you
might think well unless everything is
just the way you want it to be
then you have something to learn and
then you think well maybe the person
you're talking to no matter how
uncomfortable you are with their
opinions and how bent out of shape you
think they are maybe even how bent out
of shape they actually are there's
always the possibility that if you
actually engaged in a conversation you
ask them questions and you tried to
figure out what they thought that you'd
come away with one crumb of knowledge
more than you had when you went into the
conversation and like conversations like
that are a lot more interesting I found
in my you know I've probably done twenty
thousand hours of clinical work
something like that and so that's 20 000
hours of really really really really
really serious conversations and there
are almost always interesting beyond
belief and like I've had clients that's
I told you already that sort of spanned
the entire Spectrum from people who were
so
impaired cognitively and behaviorally
that while they were utterly
unemployable by any any reasonable
standards to people who were
unbelievably high functioning and I
found working with all of them if I if
I'm in the zone properly it's
ridiculously fascinating yeah because
people are ridiculously interesting and
so and and everyone has their own
characteristic experience that's
actually unique and so if you have a
real conversation with someone and they
tell you what's unique about their
experience the probability that you can
learn something from that is it's it's
well it's it's certain that you can my
my low IQ clients God they taught me so
much it's just they taught me how
difficult things were first you know
because to see someone struggle with a
task that the typical person can do
without even thinking sheds light on
exactly how amazing it is that
that normal people can do that and how
hard it is when when you're impaired to
the point where those sorts of normal
behaviors become
become impossible it's so enlightening
it teaches you a lot about the world and
so
I think part of the reason that YouTube
is killing television is partly because
it's technologically advantageous I mean
make no mistake about it there's nothing
that TV can do that YouTube can't do and
there's a whole bunch of things that
YouTube can do that TV can't so it's
obvious which one's going to win but
what's also interesting about it is that
there seems to be a massive and
relatively untapped market for actual
conversation and it's because
conversation is
between people of Good Will who are
trying to tell the truth we're trying to
aim at making things better is
unbelievably valuable I mean at least in
principle that's what we're all doing
here right I mean even though you know
you guys aren't talking
um that doesn't mean this isn't a
conversation you know it's first of all
we're trying to pay attention to you at
least enough to see if everyone is
engaged in the conversation if if you're
not engaged in it then it would be
completely pointless right and you want
to involve them in your experiment that
was amazing well one of the things I
learned in my clinical practice is that
if the conversation wasn't interesting
then I was doing it wrong yeah that's
right it's just and that's a really cool
thing too I think that also speaks to
this idea of a universal ethic I've
really become interested I talked about
this with Ian mcgilchrist recently I
just released that video today but it
was a week ago on a different site
um I barely become interested in the
idea that the sense of Engagement of
meaningful engagement is the deepest of
cognitive instincts I actually think you
can make a very strong neurobiological
case for that and that that if you're
engaged in something what it means is
that you're safe and secure on the one
hand sufficiently safe and secure you're
in your domain of competence which is a
good place to be you know it's like
explored territory so you're with within
the walls where you're safe but you're
also peering over the fence into same
time right so if you're engaged what it
means is that you're in your domain of
competence but you're operating within
that domain of competence so that you're
expanding your competence at the same
time and so you feel that as
meaningfully engaged meaningfully
engaging and it is
and so and I do also think that that
sense of meaningful engagement is the
right antidote to the suffering that's
that's that's part and parcel of our
limited existence it's like you need an
antidote to the fact that life is
suffering and the the experience of
meaningful engagement I think is that
antidote and I also think that the
experience of meaningful engagement is a
marker that you're where you should be
doing what you should be at the right
time I think it's the deepest of
cognitive instincts also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is develop your
communication skills I'm incredibly
nervous to uh talk in front of you
because you've got to be one of the most
formidable people that I've ever heard
of or ever listened to or ever seen so
my question is again you're one of the
best communicators that I've ever
listened to
if I could be
half as good at you or at communicating
As You Are
I would be set how can I teach myself to
do that practice
you know really like
well there's a couple of things
to read
a lot
it really helps to write
so if you want to make yourself
articulate
which is a very good idea
then
not only should you read but you should
write down what you think
and if you can do that a little bit
every day
15 minutes maybe you could steal 15
minutes and do it every day but if you
do that for 10 years you really
straighten out your thinking
if you're going to speak
effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you know so if you this is
often difficult for beginning lectures
at University because they'll do a
lecture on a topic but they only know as
much as they're saying in the lecture
and they get kind of stuck to their
notes because of it but you want to know
10 times as much as you are saying in
the lecture and then you can
specify a stepping path through it and
elaborate with the other things that you
know but to do that you have to do a lot
of reading but you also have to do a lot
of reading because that's where the
synthesize that's where the synthesizing
comes
so that's on the input side and then on
the output side well there's some tricks
techniques let's say is like if you're
speaking in front of a group you are not
delivering a talk to a group
that's not what you're doing the talk
isn't a package thing that you present
to a group there isn't a group
there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier too
because you know how to talk to a person
it's like can you talk to a thousand
people well probably not because it's
too intimidating but there isn't a
thousand people there there's
a thousand individuals and so you just
look at an individual and you say
something and you can tell if they're
engaged
they look confused or they look
interested or they look angry or they
look bored or maybe they're asleep in
which case you look at someone else
and they they give you feedback about
how you're doing and so one thing is to
to have something to say yeah but the
next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to Because unless you're
very badly socialized then that seems
unlikely in your case because you know
you present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but in first but on
First Sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural
wealth of of social skill will manifest
itself is extremely high and so you
don't deliver a talk to an audience
that's a really bad way of thinking
about you're actually engaged in a
conversation with an audience even if
they're not talking they're nodding and
shifting position and you know looking
like this or and you can you can pull
all that in and and use it to govern the
level at which you're addressing the
entire audience
so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could buttress that to some degree
and there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent
in everything you do than to learn how
to communicate I don't care if you're
going to be a carpenter I mean being a
carpenter by the way is very difficult
especially if you're a good Carpenter
but if you're good at communicating as a
carpenter you're like 10 times better as
a carpenter
so the and this is something that the
liberal arts colleges I think I don't
know if they've forgotten it but they
don't do a very good job of marketing
it's like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something
it's like
the economic value of that is
incalculable the people that I've
watched in my life who've been
spectacularly successful are they have
skills
clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful
well that's kind of like the definition
of success in life right you negotiate
and you're six doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're a really good negotiator
everybody walks away from the
negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you
so and that's all that's all dependent
on your ability to communicate so
practice rule number five is be
knowledgeable you have written an
article on how to write can you do the
same on how to speak
well I suppose I could I could tell you
a little bit about it
um
if you're going to speak about something
you need to know a lot about it you need
to know three or four times as much as
you're going to speak about at minimum
so first of all you have to do your
background research
you have to have multiple stories at
hand that you can use to illustrate your
point and you have to have a point you
have to organize what you're talking
about around a problem so before I go on
stage to speak on my tour I always sit
for half an hour some of which involves
usually about five minutes of anxiety
and I think okay there's a problem I'm
trying to address tonight a central
problem or a theme what is it might be
courage it might be responsibility it
might be meaning
I think and that serves as an organizing
principle so that would be the point and
then basically I organize say a dozen
stories around that and I can kind of
arrange them in it as a journey and it's
a journey that circles the main point
and so I'm trying to explore it to say
what I think about courage let's say but
to take what I'm thinking farther than
I've taken it already and so that I can
plot out you know no little five minute
stories that I have
that are associated with courage and
then I can talk to the audience and
I would say talk about what you know
use your personal experience because
that's that's something that you're
actually a master of you can bring in
other material but it has to be tied to
the real world through your own
experience otherwise it's not real
it's also very good to speak directly to
the audience to the individuals in the
audience because I'm always looking at a
single person one after another and
focusing on them and talking to them
just like you'd have a conversation with
someone and that way I can see if
they're following along and I'm always
listening to the audience
what I really like to hear from the
audience is no noise at all silence
because if the audience especially you
know if it's a couple hundred or a
couple of thousand people if the
audience is dead silent then
I know that I'm on the right track
and so
and the other thing I would say is
you're telling stories
so every fact that you relate or every
set of facts has to be tied to a story
there has to be a meaningful output
which is something like why is it
important to your life that you know
this fact how is it related to how
you're going to conduct yourself moving
forward or how are you going to see the
world so because that's kind of the
essence of meaning how does this fact
change the way you perceive the world or
act in the world that's the meaning of
the fact and facts without meaning are
dull so you need to know that you need
to tell the truth that's for sure and
and
I mean for me my talks are really
they're an attempt to explore a set of
ideas in the most truthful way that I
can manage and that's also an adventure
because
letting yourself speak freely about a
topic you don't always know where it's
going to go and so but that also hooks
in the audience because they're not
they're along for the ride right and
there's a risk the risk is you might
forget where you are you might lose the
thread you might say something you
regret you might get confused
and it's this the talk should be a
process of exploration like a journey
that you're taking the audience Along on
it's the same when you're reading a
novel like a great novel isn't exactly
plotted out from beginning to end to
begin with the author is taking himself
or herself and you on an intellectual
Adventure through the through the
character development and the characters
have to be allowed to live and to
express themselves and the novel needs
to unfold it's like a collacoid between
the conscious mind and the unconscious
source of inspiration and the novel is
actually a journey
through a characterological landscape
and the author shouldn't know where he
or she's going to end up at the
beginning same with an artist and who's
who's writing a song or or a piece of
music or a piece of visual art there has
to be play and exploration along the way
and so
you also don't want to deliver an over
prepared talk in my estimation or at
least that's not how I do it you want to
have a theme you want to have a body of
knowledge from which you can draw on and
then you want to be actively exploring
the idea in front of the audience and
that's very gripping for everyone
including you and so and you should
learn something from the talk it's an
opportunity to think on your feet and
rule number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is improve your
thinking I've been thinking through
um the importance of free speech I
suppose from a psychological perspective
and
it seems to me that well we can walk
through some axioms and you can tell me
what you think about them if you would
so
I mean the first thing we might posit is
that
it's useful to think it's better to
think than not to think and that might
seem self-evident but
but thought can be Troublesome and and
stir up trouble and your thoughts can be
inaccurate so
it's perhaps not that
um unreasonable to start the questioning
there but
I think it was Alfred North Whitehead
who said that
thinking allows our thoughts to die
instead of us
and so
he was thinking about the evolution of
thought in some sense from a biological
perspective so imagine a creature that's
incapable of thought has to act
something out
a representation of the world or an
intent it has to be embodied and then if
that fails
well it fails in action and so the
consequence of that might be death it
might be very severe whereas once you
can think
you can represent the world abstractly
you can divorce the abstraction from the
world and then you can produce
avatars of yourself
sometimes an image like in dreams let's
say or in literature in fiction in
movies and so on produce avatars of
ourselves that are fictional and then
run them as simulations in the abstract
world and observe the consequences and
we do that in our stories we do that
when we dream we do that when we imagine
in images and depict a dramatic scenario
playing itself out but then we also do
that in words because we encode those
images it's one more level of
abstraction we encode those images into
words and those words become partial
dramatic avatars and then the words can
battle with one another so thought seems
to work let's say verbal thought you ask
yourself a question
you receive an answer in some mysterious
manner there's an internal revelation of
sorts that's the spontaneous thought you
know when you sit down to write a book
thoughts come to you perhaps because you
pose yourself a question and no one
knows how that works but we experience
it the thoughts manifest themselves in
the theater of our imagination so that's
the revelatory aspect and then there's
the critical aspect which is
well now you've thought this and perhaps
you've written it down can you generate
counter positions are are there
universes that you can imagine where
this doesn't apply are there situations
where it doesn't apply are there better
ways of formulating that thought and but
I would say with regard to critical
thought and to some degree with regard
to productive thought
an indeterminate
proportion of that is dependent on
speech
I I don't think it's unreasonable to
point out that thought is internalized
speech and that the dialectical process
that constitutes critical thinking is
internalized speech so you and I are
engaging in a dialectic Enterprise
you'll posit something and I'll respond
to it and you'll respond to that and
we're we're
we're in a kind of combat there's some
cooperation about it as well
and we're attempting to formulate a
truth more clearly at least in principle
if we're being honest
we do that when we're speaking so our
thought the quality of our thought is
actually dependent on our ability to
speak our minds
one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer you become susceptible
to thinking you have the life
I grew up in a little town in Louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
uh you probably hear the accent
and uh I grew up in a middle class a
middle class family my my dad died when
I was 10 years old my mother raised us
and my mother constantly told me how
proud I should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
every time my mom was my best friend and
every time I would have a success it
didn't matter whether I was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime I had a success
she was the first person I called I
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
people that were closest to me I called
my mom said Mom you'd never believe I
just bought a real estate deal I started
this company I bought my first real
estate deals 38 units it's four million
dollars and she'd be like that's awesome
I love you Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action it is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all it's impossible try doing
it right now
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true I wouldn't put
it in the book If I rewrote it the
second level of action is
um to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay I was up late whatever you
came up with whatever reason I'm gonna
make the call
by the way any retreat in life any
single Retreat is a discipline and a
commitment
to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
no I'm not there
okay and I know how much I'm grinding
every day how much I'm pushing every day
how how many how many hours I put in
today what's the maximum number of hours
you can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to be outside of that moment
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x
I'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me and the reason
when I closed the book The reason I was
like ah whatever I had figured out what
I had done wrong okay I had to embrace
the the the idea that three or four
million dollars in a bank and a house
paid for and two cars and a marriage and
I got it better than everybody else and
my mama loves me just the way I am was
all this this middle class
this American particularly here in
America how many of you live in America
okay in America the middle class it is
the sleeping chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class dude I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
bad just going to college
well because what are they manufacture
in college
they manufacture average people at
college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer you wanted to be a professional
baseball player right yep but then you
got an injury they did similar to me so
you never made it to the big leagues or
did you play minor league I did yeah and
I played division one college baseball
too yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways I don't know you weren't going
to be in The Bigs for I wasn't I played
enough baseball with guys who ended up
in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking this before we
went on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were their career
changes I went into a like anybody like
whatever your dream is when the first
one ends it doesn't happen whether that
be a relationship it could be your
marriage it ends it was a dream right or
a business venture or a sport I went
into a pretty good depression and uh and
how old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up to press I ended up moving back
at home with my parents I was living in
the city I remember I was living in this
sleeping in the same bed I grew up in
with the same teddy bear the same
posters I was like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after baseball end when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
later that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
that's right down the street in San
Dimas you're going to be working with
kids doesn't pay anything at six bucks
an hour but you're gonna get this damn
job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm at mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh yeah we know that too and so
they bring me to the guy and he says uh
you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became I'm this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like McKinley is a massive
campus full of children that have been
displaced from their homes that live in
individual like Cottages like a foster
care facility massive though really yeah
all boys
it's in San Dimas here and wow it just
altered my life man because I I'd been
an athlete had a huge ego had that mask
I wanted to compete I wanted to win I
wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I was in a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
this year and I was there for two years
two years yeah man like eight hours a
day type of thing or sometimes more
sometimes 16 18. I I think about I'm not
kidding you I think about my boys and my
experience there two of them are still
very close with me uh every day there's
a moment where I reflect on that it
altered me completely like what I wanted
to do I always wanted to be famous and
Rich and successful and now I just
wanted to serve yeah I wanted to help
the little did I find out I could get
rich and famous and all that other stuff
I thought I wanted through serving
people every day of Our Lives we live in
a world that is incredibly complex and
you have to remember we all have a two
million year old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we can do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern and the
breathing pattern if you're familiar
with yogas like Breath of Fire it's
similar to Breath of Fire and it's a
movement what it's going to look like is
this you're going to sit up in your
chair with energy we're going to raise
our hands up as we take the air in and
then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow it out your nose and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling you might
notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another 30 we'll relax and then another
so we're gonna do three sets of thirty
three sets of ten ten ten ten ten ten
ten ten with a break between them when
you're done with that you're ready to
Prime because it puts you in state
priming is three actions it's done in
ten minutes you can do more than ten and
many of you will enjoy it so much you'll
go longer but the reason I do 10 minutes
of priming is I wanted to come up with a
daily discipline there was no excuse not
to do if you don't have 10 [ __ ]
minutes for your life you don't have a
life so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do our three sets of ten three
sets of ten three sets of ten then when
their eyes closed the first three and a
third minutes of the ten minutes is
we're going to focus on three
experiences in our life that we can feel
deeply grateful for three of them and
we're not going to think I'm like oh
this this we're gonna take them one at a
time spend about a minute each and step
into that moment in your life that you
could feel grateful for it could be a
little thing or a big thing it doesn't
matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it like to be
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there you're going to give me a
very different feedback than if I get
you to imagine the moment you're going
over the edge and you're in the front
seat then you're going to show me a
different result you want your gratitude
to be in the front seat not an
intellectual gratitude out there
so I take three minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggest
you cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face or the smell of
the ocean if I'm doing it outside by my
house or the look on one of my
children's faces and I'll just fill that
up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it savor it live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're gonna do is you're
gonna feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is Imagine uh energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up
and you don't have to do this with your
hands but I'm trying to show you what
the feeling is and while you're doing
this what you're going to do during
those three minutes is you're going to
give thanks it's like a prayer saying
heal my body my mind my emotions
strengthen me make me the best I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the three minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
half I then take that energy through me
and I send it in a circle around to my
children to my family to my friends to
my co-workers to my associates to my
partners to the people I meet in the
street to my clients and so it's taking
the energy and now you might sound like
woo-woo stuff but the idea of allowing
your nervous system to heal and
strengthen just the focus of that alone
for you is strong and sending to others
as well so you can think it's all
[ __ ] but try it and decide based on
the experience if you do it a while I
think you're going to find it'll deepen
that sense of gratitude because it
becomes not only gratitude but healing
is strengthening and a gift to those you
love the last three minutes I call three
to thrive you're going to think of three
things that you really want to
accomplish or achieve but instead of
like hoping it happens or thinking about
it happening you're going to step in
your mind and experience it as if it's
done you're going to see it or feel it
breathe it celebrate it like you've
already achieved the goal what you're
doing is training your reticular
activating system and we talked about
this the other day the part of your
brain that notices things when you did
you know before you bought that car
outfit you never noticed them now you
buy that car outfit those cars and
outfits are everywhere how come because
your Ras now that your own one says this
is important I need to pay attention to
this well when you get clear what you
want and you see it as done and feel it
and create it in your mind in your heart
and you celebrate it there's a sense of
certainty then there's your body and
your reticular activated system starts
to go to work on making it happen so you
spend a minute each one of those so
basically three minutes each three and
third minutes each and we're done when
it comes to an affirmation affirmations
can be powerful
um and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the affirmation is so powerful how come
I'm not experiencing the effect the what
scientists tell us is the average human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day
some of those thoughts are the words to
the songs and they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility
as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's subtle and it's powerful it's
not making something happen out there
and that means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community uh as to whether or not I
would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
uh their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path and when
we began as a scientist beginning to
understand these relationships gave me
the reason to think differently
and they'll also give me the reason to
test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't when you're
going on a long car trip you take your
car to the mechanic first right to get
things recalibrated realigned and ready
to go that's our second M how we're
going to recalibrate for our new journey
is to adjust our self-awareness
neuroscientist David Eagleman says that
as far as our brains are concerned as
adults we are more like our peers than
our childhood selves yeah when we think
about who we are we mostly base our
ideas on our younger self so tune up
your self-awareness you're going to go
on a data Gathering Expedition among
those who know you best Simon sinek the
author of start with wire has a great
exercise for this when people say I
don't know what I'm good at or I don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right there's a saying that you
can't read the label from inside the job
so you're going to ask people outside
your jaw to help you out can you help me
you're going to ask three to five people
who know you well it may be personal
professional friends to describe for you
what makes you special ask them Simon
recommends why are you friends with me
why did you pick me as your partner or
what makes me stand out as an employee
what do you really like about me as your
parent now beware most people will
answer first with something general
you're smart you're funny you're a good
listener that's not deep enough anything
else ask for more for example lots of
people are funny why are you friends
with me instead of someone else who's
funny or lots of employees are dedicated
can you give me more detail like a
specific incident or example that really
showed you that tell me more then you
start getting the truly helpful data and
information such as I love the way you
use humor to make other people feel
welcome and comfortable or you have this
ability to take our discussions Deeper
by bringing in insights from lots of
other fields very nice of you to say you
start to see yourself through others
eyes and get an understanding of what's
working what your strengths are that you
can go deeper on and maximize and What
Makes You uniquely you here's an awesome
idea convene a feel-good Roundtable in
person or over Zoom with a few good
friends or family members or even do
this with co-workers where you go around
and tell each other some of your
greatest strengths in detail then you're
spreading the love and the joy and the
support as well and it doesn't feel as
awkward as just asking it for yourself
please don't make this awkward for me
okay so what else do we need to start a
journey strong we need some idea of
where we're going right a map that's our
third end you've just learned about all
these great things you've got going for
you but no doubt you also have an area
of 2 or 12 that's me where you'd like to
grow so we're going to create a map of
how to get there and one way you can do
that is to pick a mentor someone who
embodies that quality or those qualities
you're looking to grow this year one of
my greatest mentors is Martin Luther
King Jr specifically the way he inspired
people for a meaningful cause and
connected people to his powerful words
maybe if you want to become better at
relating to others your Mentor is Oprah
Winfrey maybe if you want to be more
strategic and thoughtful when it comes
to business it's your father or mother
that was the case for John Mackey the
founder of Whole Foods his father was
his business Mentor for years maybe if
you want to cultivate Innovation or
persistence your Mentor is someone like
Sir James Dyson or Richard Branson next
figure out basic simple ways to connect
with your Mentor regularly if it's not
someone you can connect with in real
life you can read their work watch their
videos listen to a podcast read about
their lives tape an inspiring fact about
them or quote from them above your desk
or put it into your wallet remember it's
not that you want to mimic your Mentor
you want to be yourself and combine
those strands Your Divine developing
with those great strengths you already
have in place but if you look at some of
the geography your Mentor has traveled
it can help provide you with your own
map for developing those strengths it
dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results communication is
one of the most important skills that
entrepreneurs need to have and I think a
lot of businesses fail because the
entrepreneur cannot communicate well and
if they even are sharing their ideas
they are not convincing enough and so a
lot of great ideas die you could have
the next greatest idea that can change
the world it's sitting up here
but because you can't articulate it
because you can't share it because you
can't communicate it well and because
you're not convincing enough to the
people around you it will never take off
the idea will die within you and I hate
that I hate that because building a
business getting the thing that's out
here out into the world is greater than
one person no matter how much of a
genius you are to build a business you
need a team you need a team of people to
help you go far and you also need to
convince the media and customers and
partners and suppliers that what you
have is amazing
if you are the only one who thinks that
your idea is amazing and you can't
communicate or convince anybody else of
that then you're done then that idea
dies within you and I think
unfortunately that's a lot of
entrepreneurs so Jordan has three of his
tips I'm gonna give you three of mine on
how to be a convincing Communicator step
number one is have a powerful opinion
you have an opinion what is it that you
are trying to say make it mean something
to yourself and to me and make that the
first sentence of every piece of content
that you make if you're doing a video
that's your first sentence you do an
Instagram post put it in there you're
doing a LinkedIn post an email a
newsletter like put it in there you lead
with your powerful opinion on what is
wrong with the world or what your
viewpoint on XYZ topic is make it mean
something to me make me care so if I'm
talking about communication how
important it is for entrepreneurs a
powerful opinion would be something like
you need to learn how to communicate in
your business or you will never get that
idea that's in your head out into the
world and your idea will die inside you
that's an opinion where lots of people
might say something like so
if you want to learn how to build a
successful business and maybe take your
idea to the next level I think maybe you
should focus on trying to improve how
you speak and communicate like it's so
long it has lots of filler words you use
words like maybe and potentially and
someday and one day and I wish and we
instead of I like affirmative stop
worrying about what people's reactions
are going to be and speak your truth
always lead with a powerful opinion tip
number two is emotional commitment this
is where a lot of entrepreneurs really
fall down you've got your powerful
opinion you know what you stand for you
know what you're trying to communicate
but when you get in front of a camera or
when you get down to writing it doesn't
sway people it's not emotional enough
you could be saying all the best words
when you get in front of a camera to
make a video but because you are talking
in a very boring very non-exciting
Manner and because you're so worried
about saying the perfect words that you
are memorizing something or you are
looking at your script or trying to read
from a teleprompter nobody is going to
care or listen to you
you need to have emotional commitment
you need to feel the thing and how
important it is while you are saying it
for me I'm envisioning all of you I'm
envisioning all the entrepreneurs that
I've worked with who have these Amazing
Ideas and they never get them out
because they can't communicate and even
though I'm sitting here in an office by
myself and there's nobody around to
actually connect with I'm just talking
to a camera I'm trying to channel you
I'm trying to Channel all the people
that I've connected with and seen and I
want to make sure that your business
does well
and communicating is so important as
part of that which is why I'm doing this
video and hopefully the care the love
the energy comes through in the content
that I make and so sales and convincing
people not enough against what they want
but in a positive way like this is
something that you guys can get together
on is about the energy transfer you are
not just selling a concept or an idea
you are transferring energy whoever is
more confident wins whoever is more
convincing wins and it's usually from
whoever believes in their thing more if
you absolutely believe in your thinking
that this is right and it's for them and
they need to do this thing because it's
in their best interest not because
they're just trying to sell something
down their throat but you really really
really really really care
and if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying
that's how you bring them on board
it's great to have the best words but
more important is the emotional
commitment that you have behind them
so the best test with any of this is
watch back some of your content like
watch back your videos read your
newsletters see the copy on your website
look at the story that you wrote about
yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom boom like
yes that's right that's why I do this
thing or do you watch it and you get
bored
you should get bored and it doesn't get
your heart beating then do it again do
it again and do it again and do it again
and do it again you will be one of your
best critics you will be one of your
harshest critics and so being able to
look over your content and get to the
point where you say wow
yeah I'm really proud of that
that's when you start to win and tip
number three is raise the stakes just
make it more important if you want to
move people so often we're focused just
on the tactics the strategies here's the
five things that you need to do and
people say yeah yeah yeah great I love
those the five things awesome they write
them down and then they never do
anything about it you need to raise the
stakes you have to make it more
important you have to make me feel the
pressure that if I don't do this thing
that you want me to do terrible things
will happen right so if I talk about how
important communication is me just
saying communication is really important
as an entrepreneur here are the three
ways to do it it's not as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you don't learn how
to communicate your ID and get it out
there that idea will die inside you and
your mission will never be realized
and listen that paints a dark picture
that's going to an extreme and the idea
is not to have Hyperbole and make things
bigger than they are but that's a real
case for tons of entrepreneurs that if
they do not learn how to communicate
properly their ideas will never get out
there and their idea will die inside
them and so your goal if you want to
move people is to make them realize how
big this thing is for them if they don't
take action you're the expert you know
where the road is going you see their
future if they continue down that path
they don't see that future they don't
understand it it's your job to help them
see where this current path of action is
going to lead them and if they make the
tweak they make the change they take
your recommendations where it could go
raise the stakes make it more important
make them feel that it's more important
and it actually starts with you feeling
that this message is insanely important
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for five
ways to improve your communication
skills check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
connecting increases your influence
in every situation
for the foundation of the teaching today
I want to make sure that we really have
a grasp of why connecting with people is
so vital